gritan libertad con las esperanzas de
llegar a casa tiempo para la navidad
cada vez más mermadas algunos se
enfrentaron a la policía una frustración
que se tradujo en arrestos pues son
muchos los que llevan varios días
bloqueados en el puerto
don't know what
no tenemos comida no tenemos baños
esperamos poder hacernos un test hoy
para estar mañana en navidad con
nuestras familias
llevamos aquí tres días por primera vez
ayer en la tarde recibimos algo de apoyo
que fueron tres botellas de agua y un
paquete de papas tras cerrar
abruptamente la frontera con reino unido
el domingo francia aceptó dejar pasar a
los viajeros esenciales y camioneros en
el caso de que hubieran dado negativo
por kobe en las 72 horas previas las
colas en dover ya eran de docenas de
kilómetros antes de cerrar la frontera
ya que la perspectiva de no conseguir un
acuerdo de 'break' si hizo que miles se
apresuraron a llevar bienes a europa
antes de fin de año a pesar de que los
ferry reactivaron el transporte de
pasajeros y bienes el caos está lejos de
terminar
algunos coches han bloqueado la entrada
al puerto porque no dieron negativo en
la prueba pero no quieren hacer espacio
para aquellos que sí
no hay sitios para hacer pruebas a los
conductores no hay nadie ayudando algo
de buenas noticias las autoridades
francesas están aceptando pruebas de
antígenos que son más rápidas y
sencillas que la especie r el acuerdo
entre francia y reino unido- podría
durar hasta el 6 de enero en función de
la propagación del virus otras naciones
europeas como alemania han decidido
mantener la prohibición de viaje